what i
tell young people who are looking for
advice i say you know your
the skill you need to refine is the
ability to learn your skills
like if you become good at learning a
new skill
and tim ferriss a friend of mine has
really pioneered this like
he can get to 60 or 70 percent
of like the knowledge in a skill in some
incredibly short period of time now i'm
not saying he's gonna become a virtuoso
drummer
or a great basketball player but tim and
i were on vacation
together in like a group vacation in
italy and there was a basketball court
and uh i said let's go let's go shoot
some hoops i never shoot shot before and
i was like okay come on
i'll teach you and tim is fabulously
uncoordinated people don't know this
yes like he tried to dribble a
basketball and do a layup yeah and it
looked like
he had a blindfold on i mean you've
never seen something
less elegant than tim ferriss doing a
layup in basketball and then
he watched me do it three or four times
and i watched him
study me and listen i've been playing
basketball in brooklyn since i was a kid
i got a couple of moves and he was just
taking notes and taking notes and taking
notes and by the end of a couple of
hours of doing this
i could just watch him checking his form
and figuring it out
that's every skill in the world now and
what i tell people is like
i'm like have you did you watch game of
thrones and they're like yeah
watch breaking bad like yeah i'm like
okay that's about 400 hours yeah
how about you don't watch the next two
and you put that 400 hours into learning
how to be a graphic designer
a ux person a developer whatever it is
and learn how to add skills that's what
i did my whole life i was a kid from
brooklyn
went to school at night but i was very
quick to get to maybe 50
of the knowledge base of graphic design
or being a writer or being a sales
executive whatever it was a developer
even
and i was just good enough to not have
people be able to me like when
i hired them
and that was a big unlock when you know
enough that people
can't snow you that's a really good one
and look at yourself like
you figured out how to set up an entire
podcast people don't know this but
you don't have a team around you i have
a team of like five six people working
on my podcast you see even knowing
enough about to set this up
you would then be able to hire a team
correct and you'll be able to call them
on their if
they're not doing a good job and that's
really important and i don't know that
much about this whole thing but i know
enough to be able to then
see who knows their stuff or not you're
absolutely right and then
the process of learning how to learn is
uh
is essential there because uh i have uh
i did martial arts uh jiu-jitsu and so
on and it's so funny to watch i did take
one
yeah that was awesome it's funny that
there's some people that
do an activity for years because
to sort of elaborate on something you
were saying about uh hours
it's not always the amount of hours it's
the quality that you put in
deliberate practice versus just doing
some behavior i mean
literally i've been playing chess and
trying to get that going again after
watching queen's gambit and i got
chess.com
and i realized i was just playing and
i'm not getting better and then i was
like oh wait there's a little analysis
feature here in jazz.com
where it will show you your blunders and
mistakes and i'm like oh
i'm spending no time reviewing my losses
in chess
and i just want to play the next game i
should really review these losses and
figure out what mistakes i made when i
started doing that i was like oh i'm
getting better
yeah right so some deliberate practice
really well and if you want to take it
all the way uh magnus carlsen
uh shout out to the guy he has an app
but there's a few other coaching apps
where you like focus on the end game you
focus
drilling a particular it's you basically
don't play the game at all you're just
focused on drilling the
the different apps openings the openings
yeah and there's different kinds of
puzzles so you can really make it into a
deliberate practice not to make this
episode sponsored by chess.com but they
literally have puzzles yeah so i was
like
oh and it's a hundred dollars a year for
this product and i just thought to
myself
this is capitalism they don't need to
charge you a hundred dollars an hour for
a lesson
they can charge you a hundred dollars
and they've created the ability for you
to play chess 24 hours a day
against opponents who are perfectly
matched against you based on your rating
and they analyze every game and they
have puzzles and they have tutorials and
they've got everything else
it's like just think about how much
value is being provided to society
because of capitalism and because
competition if you want things to get
better
and you want to step up your game just
make it slightly competitive it is one
of these things
in human uh existence that is
so powerful i don't know did you see the
michael jordan documentary the last
dance
like half of it okay i'm still working i
mean he's so
competitive yeah and petty yeah it's so
inspiring that
all he cares about is just winning
to the level of which he literally
there's like this running meme
i took that personally and i took that
person i don't know if you've seen the
images of him
sitting smoking a cigar looking at like
an ipad or a video clip and it's like i
took that personally
and you can make a supercut of every
time he took something personally he
literally takes everything personally to
give himself that competitive motivation
to win that's capitalism and when people
are competing
man look at what elon did to the the
the space of cars like every they were
literally laughing at him in the first
10 years electric cars ha ha
that company will go out of business and
now every single company is like
we're going fully electric by 2035 and
he
kicked their asses so brutally that
they had no choice but then to step up
their game
you